i was planning my second world
championship with team usa we had by
most counts the best team to ever play
and we got upset in the final and and
lost the gold medal to canada and the
following week went back to my pro team
in boston and i broke my foot so like at
the time i lost what was considered the
biggest game in like american lacrosse
history and i was
you know the top player on the team
and i broke my foot and it was like okay
my career is over um and i went into
this like depressive state and was up on
my couch all day for
you know four months and my agency at
the time was like i think you should
meet this sports psychologist that works
with some of our other athletes
and that's where it started but it was
more focused on like hey your career is
not over you're 28 you're at the top of
your game this happens a lot of athletes
you're going to be fine
and it led to other things like dealing
with frustrations on the field being
more mindful and present in the locker
room building better relationships with
teammates
um and then that led me into meditation
and then i was using an app called
headspace at the time yeah i've used
that yeah and my like
kind of entrepreneurial mind was like i
wonder who's the guy who started this
what's the business like is it
successful so i looked up andy puticum
and i read his story and he was a
converted
uh christian or some denomination over
to a monk and then
found a business partner that he was
helping um just on the psychology side
say hey let me leave my ad agency and
i'm like selling headspace right now um
but
yeah and it was it was a story for me
and
you know fast forward to actually you
asked about 2020
so red bull was still one of my partners
and they knew that i'd been on the app
for seven years or so and and uh they
connected me with andy potikum and i had
a private
session with him which was like a dream
[Laughter]
um so yeah life works its way out in so
many wow
well i mean
you know i feel like the basis of
buddhism
has so much to do with the self and
accountability and going within yourself
and
you know i even just think about you you
starting the lacrosse league premier la
costa lacrosse league that
it's about you just said to yourself
kind of like you just did
well why don't i just do it myself right
why don't i just start the league it's
it's accountability it's something you
can do yourself instead of looking at it
in the other way which is it's someone
else's problem which i i i'm there's so
many wonderful things about all
religions i just think that
you know there's some downfalls too and
allowing some like putting your problem
onto somebody or something else to solve
it is just not going to fix it and so if
you were to look at
lacrosse and say
oh i can't believe this isn't bigger i
can't believe and so instead it's like
this mindset or this new
paradigm that you live in where you go
hmm
how could i do this what what could i do
to it's like full accountability and i
think that as people we're completely
limitless and it's totally our
environment it's our it's our
our upbringing as well as our friends
and the people that we know and our
social situation and where we live and
there's so many things that sort of
craft our
opinion or perspective of how things are
supposed to go but it's limitless
and when you start to like realize that
you just go oh i don't know i'll just
start a league then yeah me that feels
like a like a branch of buddhism in a
way
yeah
in a way for sure i i think that
i mean and to be honest i was a part of
the cohort of people that would always
go why isn't it better why don't they
just do the work and
uh man for for building a league it
actually was so much work and more than
we even accounted for
and there were many times where we
kind of sat across the room from each
other and mike and i just been like
this is this is too much and also no
wonder the former owners were in many
cases like [ __ ] this and we're not going
to do this and we'll just continue to
invest bare minimum and hopefully
um you know the pendulum swings in la
lacrosse's direction on its own which
historically has never happened in any
league
not the nba
not the nfl not major league baseball
there's no professional sport that has
gained momentum from bottom-up growth
those sports are actually olympic sports
and they only come every four years
there's a reason why
i saw lots of them and i'm like that's a
sport there are so many amazing sports
out there that haven't figured out the
professional side of it yet and they can
go away after college well then how do
you do it if it's not bottom up then
what is it
that's that's the that was the challenge
we were like all right we've got to
raise capital we've got to hire a bunch
of hard-working employees to roll our
[ __ ] sleeves up every single day take
20 no's every single day and go out and
try to build this thing
and it's going to take a ton of energy
it's going to be
more uh
more difficult than it is easy and will
only get more difficult it's basically a
startup
exactly i mean it's it's building a
company it's the same thing
if if we weren't as athletes growing up
so consumed by the fun of our sport
and how much we enjoyed it
we would have taken a step back and been
like god damn look how much work we're
putting into this every single day
and it's sometimes the the own fault of
us as a league
and athletes that
we only often get depicted for their
greatness and all of the progress
and that creates this false narrative in
a way people i've talked about with don
garber who's become a mentor and
um and friend and he's the commissioner
of mls and what they've done over the
last 25 30 years and what we see now
is certainly not what it was in the 90s
and he still says like every day they're
grinding and making decisions and
figuring out how to solve coven like we
did and play games
and the other side of it is their
athletes and the audience thinks that
they sit at the top of an ivory tower
and it's like you know playing a video
game and super fun and it never is it
just isn't it's hard so what makes a
sport popular
oof
well
not wearing helmets yeah not wearing
helmets
you've got to have meaningful
distribution
so one of the reasons why we built the
tour based model in the first place is
so we could get a network deal
because if we went building from the
ground up in cities with individual
owners we would have had to either
rent out stadiums in each market or
build stadiums which have taken more
capital the renting of venues makes it
really difficult for any league to build
their schedule
i mean absent in the nfl which basically
has carte blanche
like even the mls that owns all their
venues they take till middle of january
to announce their schedule because
there's so many back and forth on
optimizing who's home who's away at what
time
and then you go to the networks and say
here's our game schedule well if you
don't have any product market fit if
we're a startup as i talked about
earlier
ie ratings we're not going to get a
network deal because we have nothing to
present in 2017 when mike and i were
pitching our story so instead we went
this tour based model means we're going
to go to boston and take out gillette
for three days do you have any windows
that are available on nbc or nbc sports
that weekend and if so boom that's when
our games are
and so we kind of did like this inside
out model right to capitalize on how do
you make it popular well you get on tv
um and then the second is you get brand
brands to come in and invest and we
treat our i say invest because we treat
our sponsors like investors instead of
sponsors um they're investing in the
growth they get equity
they don't um but like that's how we
treat them right and and and like we we
plus them up we give them a ton of value
we take care of them
um because we know it's a different type
of investment that they're making it's
it's unproven especially in the first
two seasons
um and then if you get your brand
partners to come in and they're starting
to market lacrosse like gatorade is
doing for us then all of a sudden like
young kids that are seeing gatorade
typically market soccer basketball and
football they're going oh damn you know
lacrosse maybe maybe if i can be a
gatorade athlete one day i'll i'll have
a lacrosse stick
and that's how you like build it from a
media marketing standpoint and then we
always felt like if we could
roll out the red carpet if that was our
version of that by elevating wages
giving players equity and being on tv
then the product on field is going to be
kick-ass and
people are going to want to watch
lacrosse more because they like what
they see
i also think
that it takes personalities
no doubt
um
i think that's probably what i was
benefited from was people knew me people
had a taste of my personality um at
least one part of my personality which
is probably why people afterwards when i
interview drivers now they're like you
seem really
deep and spiritual and stuff is that new
i'm like no
but there was no space for that you know
that wasn't like you know something to
promote but people still saw outside of
my personality and so they you know they
can decide to cheer for you or not and
um and so i think that's probably
your popularity is that people know you
like i watched enough videos that i get
your personality to some degree you know
i i
because i saw you in a raw form i saw
you
i saw you being natural i saw you at
home i saw you cooking i saw you you
know i saw you talking to a group of
people at a school like i can see these
i can see this sort of i can see your
personality and so
you know i've i've found that to be true
too and racing itself as well when a
driver you don't always have to put it
out there yourself
um
like you said sometimes there's enough
opportunities to show it um but for for
ones who don't get that you can i mean
that's why there's like youtube
sensations they're not on tv they're
just showing their personality and so if
you have a cool skill which all your
players have cool skill and then they
show their personality then
their people are gonna follow and be
curious that's why colton heard at the
indy 500 wanted to meet you because he
saw your personality and so i've always
thought this to be true is that you know
people that aren't willing to be
vulnerable honest raw
emotions up and down whatever they are
and show them
um and somewhat promote themselves and
realize that doing the interviews and
showing up to things is important
you know i mean
it's about the effort that you put in to
show people who you are to cheer for you
it's it's one of the
you're 100 right i mean
what
really jordan did but you could say
magic and bird to the nbas of the 80s
was astronomical i mean the nba in the
80s had a horrible reputation
and they couldn't fill arenas and then
those stars came in
and david stern at the time rest in
peace switched his strategy from
building up teams to creating
enlargement of players and if you look
at what conor mcgregor did to the ufc
even though they were projecting upward
and what you were doing in racing and
you you see personalities that take a
sport to another level
some of those i mean it's like finding a
needle in the haystack to a degree of
the caliber of people that i just
mentioned where it's perfectly best at
what they do
amazing personality relatable
ambitious and you're like [ __ ] you know
this this is amazing and um but you know
we're still living in an era where
if you're a professional athlete if you
want to
get as much out of your
in the grand scheme of things short
career
you've got to step up
it for in the form of media and you've
got to be available to your audience
many many athletes don't want to do that
they just want to focus on their craft
and that's okay
they'll just never reach the point of
economic prosperity or notoriety that's
just honestly part of our business if we
believe that we're a show business which
sports just are
then you know you can participate for
skill only but you're just not going to
you know bust through the ceiling